is it so in the U.S I know if someone
gets divorced and they have a kid with a
girl in certain States they have to pay
25 percent of their after-tax income per
kid
um I don't think it's as bad here no no
is it similar or no I don't think he's
though it can be similar but I think
what the thing is I think the US is a
bit more Cutthroat yeah yeah in terms of
English law we go by Case by case and
there's more of uh there's a lot more
fairness I think from what I've seen so
far which is good because I mean in
America you have community property
states which are just
light completely just cut the house the
Assets in the middle who cares what
happened in the case yeah and that's
horrible because some cases are really
unique and they deserve attention but
then you have Equity distribution states
in America some some states